turning to russia's response to the
international outrage their decision has
been to double down on propaganda and
misinformation one example this week
russian troops took journalists to the
ruins of a theater in mariupol where a
russian missile is alleged to have
killed hundreds of civilians meanwhile
in the recaptured city of bucha
ukrainian investigators are exhuming
body bags as part of a war crimes
investigation
and in russia president putin once again
lied to his people about what's actually
happening in the war in ukraine chris
livesay is in ukraine for us again this
morning chris good morning
good morning the dust might be settling
in and around keeve as russian forces
retreat but ukraine's president warns
the war is only entering a new stage of
terror with atrocities on civilians
following every russian boot print
more and more civilian areas in flames
this time a culinary arts school in
surrounding apartments in harkev
innocent people suffering so frequently
survivors say it's hardly an accident
the russian world has arrived to protect
us says gennady in sarcastic disbelief
many thanks to putin there's nothing
more to say
human suffering the russian president
continues to deny
speaking of ukraine publicly for the
first time in more than a week he called
his war noble while shrugging off peace
talks he says have reached a dead end
and despite mounting evidence to the
contrary putin claimed that atrocities
like those committed in bucha the
aftermath witnessed by cbs news were
faked he also announced a new stage of
the war shifting his attention to the
eastern donbass region these new
satellite images show russian artillery
setting the stage for head-to-head
battles feared to be unlike anything
since world war ii we
but russia continues to suffer setbacks
oligarch victor medvedchuk the kremlin's
main agent of influence in kiev was
captured by ukrainian security agents a
humiliating loss for putin the godfather
of medvedchuk's daughter ukrainian
president vladimir zelinski is offering
a trade for ukrainian pows
exchange this guy of yours he says for
our guys and girls now held in russian
captivity
zielinski continues to rally support for
his country today he's meeting in kiev
with the presidents of poland lithuania
latvia and estonia all of them countries
that russia has invaded before and don't
want it to happen again
gail
all right thank you chris livesay in
ukraine